Herzlich willkommen zu Alternativlos, die Folge 2.0.
Dem Politpodcast mit Fefe und Frank.
Polit, wir machen noch Boulevard.
Ist das nicht dasselbe heutzutage?
Ja, wahrscheinlich ist es dasselbe.
Wolf, Merkel.
Ja, stimmt. Jetzt mit Wolf in seinem... Wo ist der gerade im urlaub? In dem Mallorca-Domizil von einem von diesen Finanzfuzzis. Und der bezahlt angeblich sogar Geld dafür. Großartig.
Gut, aber Wolf ist heute nicht unser Thema.
Nee, Wolf ist heute nicht unser Thema.
Wir machen erstmal ein paar hausmeister-sachen, haben wir gesagt.
genau, hausmeister-themen. Als allererstes müssen wir mal Tim danken. Also Tim Prüttler ist unter anderem einer der Gründe, warum wir sitzen, diesen Podcast machen. Der hat als mit so einer der ersten in unserem Umfeld entdeckt, dass Podcasten doch eine Menge Leute interessiert. Das war mir so nicht klar, weil ich nicht so richtig die Zeit habe, zu einem Podcast zu hören, aber offensichtlich gibt es eine Menge Leute, die gerne Podcasts hören und eine Menge Leute, die auch Flatter-Accounts haben und diese Kombination von Podcasten und Flattern scheint ja tatsächlich doch durchaus gewinnend zu sein. Insofern müssen wir Tim nochmal ausdrücklich danken. Da hat er den richtigen Riecher gehabt.
Im Übrigen ist ja jetzt Podcast sozusagen in die Browser eingebaut. Stimmt, damit ist die Schwelle deutlich gesunken. Früher baute man einen Beratungsunterhalt, der einem das eingerichtet hat. Die Zeiten sind größtenteils vorbei.
Also mit iTunes ging es schon immer ganz komfortabel. genau, wir sind jetzt auch auf iTunes unterwegs. Fefe dementiert jegliche Schuld daran.
Ich kann nichts dafür, genau. Das war alles Franks Schuld.
Ja, ich bin schuld. Aber wer es in iTunes klicken möchte, kann auf iTunes nach Alternativlos suchen und findet uns da auch. Ansonsten ist der Link auf der Seite Alternativlos Org auch gut verborgen im unteren rechten Drittel oder so was zu finden, wo Fefe ihn als Ostereif versteckt hat. Ja, Flattr hat erstaunlich gut funktioniert. Ich muss ja sagen, wir sind jetzt so Platz 8 oder so was der All-Time-Flattr-Charts. Wir sind gespannt auf die Endabrechnung für diesen Monat, wie viel da so rumgekommen ist, ob es vielleicht für irgendwie ein Eis reicht oder für irgendwie tolles Recording-Equipment werden wir sehen.
Wir haben übrigens an den Mikrofon-Settings ein bisschen getweekt und da ist vielleicht immer noch zusätzlicher spielraum. Das müssen wir noch ausforschen.
genau, wir basteln da immer noch so ein bisschen dran rum, wie jetzt genau die Mikrofoneinstellungen sind. Wir sitzen heute im Übrigen im kraus Computer Club Berlin im Keller. Also wenn ihr irgendwelche Geräusche hört von lachenden oder hackenden Menschen, dann sind das ja die anderen Bewohner des Clubs, die hier so ihren freitäglichen Beschäftigungen nachgehen, nicht weit davon irritieren lassen.
Spontane freudenausbrüche.
genau. Flattr hatte ich vorher ein bisschen mit meinem Blog experimentiert. Bei Alternativlos funktioniert es irgendwie doch erstaunlich gut. Da haben wir interessanterweise, was mir vorher nicht so ganz klar war, festgestellt, dass Flattr doch eine sehr deutsche Angelegenheit ist. Also von den Top 10, also den Alltime-Flattr Top 10, wenn man oben mal den Sprachfilter ausschaltet, dann sind, glaube ich, 8 von 10 oder so was, sind irgendwie deutschbar, oder 9 von 10. Das heißt also momentan scheint Flattr eine sehr deutschlastige Angelegenheit zu sein. Offensichtlich ist es in anderen Ländern noch nicht so angekommen. Was eigentlich ein bisschen schade ist, weil ich finde, das ist eigentlich eine schöne Angelegenheit, mit der man noch eine Menge Spaß haben kann. Vielleicht ändert sich das ja so, wenn Flattr von dem Einleitungsprinzip weggeht dahin, dass jeder sich ohne große Probleme einen Flattr-Account klicken kann, dann wird es möglicherweise noch ein bisschen aufwärts gehen.
Vielleicht ist das auch so ein bisschen eine Mentalitätsfrage. Die Deutschen sind auch durchaus bereit, ein bisschen was zurückzugeben.
Das Schöne an Flattr ist ja genau dieser Beteiligungseffekt. Man kann keinen Flattr-Account haben, ohne selber Geld bei Flattr auszugeben, ohne Sachen rauszuflättern. Und eigentlich eine sehr schöne Idee dabei. Es gibt ja noch so andere Systeme, wir wurden auch gefragt, ob wir zum Beispiel Kachinkel nicht verwenden. Das ist auch so ein Content-Bezahlsystem, was aber im Gegensatz zu Flattr wirklich maximal intrusiv ist. Das heißt, man ist mehr so am Facebook-Modell orientiert. Also jeder kann überall sehen, wer was geklickt hat. Und es wird auch sehr viel mehr Daten erhoben, als uns so lieb ist. Umdrehen gab es noch ein paar Usability-Probleme, deswegen haben wir gesagt, das brauchen wir nicht. Wir bleiben mal bei Flattr, gucken mal, wie sie das entwickelt. Also wir sind gespannt auf die Abrechnung, was da so bei rumkommt. Also keine Ahnung, wie viel so ein Flattr-Click wert ist.
Das werden wir dann sehen. Wir haben auch die Einbindung von Flattr umgestellt, sodass jetzt nicht mehr auf unserer Seite zu sehen ist, wie viel schon geflattert haben. Aber dafür heißt es eben auch, dass das Bild nicht von Flattr kommen muss, was datenschutzrechtlich den Vorteil hat, dass Flattr nicht sehen kann, wer auf unsere Site klickt, sondern nur wer flättern will. Da wir ja so einen datenschutzrechtlichen Hintergrund haben, eigentlich war das die ganze Zeit so geplant, das habe ich halt am Anfang verpeilt. Und jetzt ist es so.
Ja, also ändert es sozusagen nichts an der Funktionalität, sondern nur an der Optik.
Aber wir gehen auf eure Bedenken ein, würde ich sagen.
genau. Eine der interessanteren Erkenntnisse war, dass ungefähr zwei Drittel der Hörer sich den Podcast als OK runtergeladen haben und nur etwa ein Drittel als MP3. Es mag zum Teil daran liegen, dass die iTunes-Aktivierung erst relativ spät kam. Das heißt, wir an iTunes erst relativ spät vertreten waren. Es mag auch einfach daran liegen, dass irgendwie die Leser deines Blogs eher so ein bisschen rankuckenden Codec-Freunde sind.
Naja, die Browser können halt alle OK. Und deswegen, wenn man das Audio-Tech benutzt und der Browser OK kann, dann nimmt er eben die OK-Variante. Und die ist auch ein bisschen kleiner, bei eigentlich so vom Hörabgefühl gleicher Qualität. Insofern ist uns das eigentlich auch lieb, wenn ihr die kleinere Version zieht, dann geht das für euch schneller und für uns das weniger Bandbreite. Aber wir waren überrascht und am Anfang war es sogar noch krasser, da war es irgendwie dreiviertel zu ein Viertel. OK funktioniert in der breiten Masse, muss man sagen. Hat uns auch überrascht.
War ich wirklich überrascht, weil bisher hatte ich das für so eine Randgruppenkodec-Angelegenheit gehalten. Ja, wie gesagt, ansonsten sind wir jetzt auch bei iTunes, was uns direkt zu unserer allseits geliebten Firma Apple bringt. Und wie tut Apple da jetzt in letzter Zeit lauter Sachen, mit denen Microsoft niemals durchgekommen wäre? Also ich meine, wenn man sich so überlegt, so Microsoft war ja mal so vor fünf Jahren oder so, waren die ja noch so richtig schön evil.
Ja, und also Microsoft hat ein paar davon auch versucht, so ist es nicht. Aber die haben halt immer in die Fresse gekriegt. IBM hat auch so eine Dinger versucht und hat in die Fresse gekriegt. Und jetzt macht Apple das und kriegt nicht in die Fresse. Das finde ich immer, also nicht, gar nicht.
Doch vergleichsweise wenig, ja.
Die Leute kaufen das trotzdem.
Der Grund ist, glaube ich, dass es einfach funktioniert.
Also ich meine, es ist strittig, sagen wir so.
Wenn du jetzt aber irgendwie, um dabei irgendwie Extrembeispiele zu wählen, die Funktionalität eines Windows 95 wählen, die mit einem damaligen Mac OS ohne Speicherschutz vergleicht, dann ist Windows 95 immer noch vorne. Na hör mal.
Was war das damals, OS 9 oder was?
OS 9 war super, solange es nicht gecrashed hat.
Hat dir nur eine Bombe angezeigt, dass du dich direkt gekrutscht hast.
Kooperatives Multitasking, da war ich fast dead auf die Arbeit, nur fünf Jahre zu spät. Super.
Technologisch schon immer vankart.
Wenn du ein Scheißsystem hast und dann noch irgendwie wollen sie alle deine Daten haben und dich gängeln und zwängen, dann möchtest du gar nicht mehr. Dann kommen da so zwei Dinge zusammen. Wenn du hingegen ein System hast, was zumindest funktional, halbwegs okay und fluffig ist, dann bist du wahrscheinlich eher bereit zu tolerieren, dass sie dann auch noch deine Daten haben wollen und dich auf ein Device einsperren und dir nicht erlauben, die Software zu installieren, die du installieren möchtest und was sonst noch für Sachen sich Apple da gerade so ausgedacht hat.
Also ich glaube ja fast, dass es unter den Apple-Leuten weniger Datenschutzbewusstsein generell gibt. Denn so Sachen wie.mec, die haben ja sowas wie Gmail angeboten. Du hast ja auch einen eigenen Webspace gehabt. Und es war so ein Zehntel der Kapazität der Konkurrenz und es hat Geld gekostet und du musstest einmal Datenstriptease machen. Also, dass sowas überhaupt...
Darf ich was sagen? Es war halt nur ein Klick. Also, es war tatsächlich... Ja, ja, genau.
Aber ich meine, also das ist einfach eine Abwägung, die an der Stelle nur, wenn Datenschutz nicht so auf deinem Radar ist, pro Apple ausgehen kann.
De facto ist es dasselbe, was Google jetzt macht, wenn du zum Beispiel so ein Android-Phone kaufst.
Ja.
Funktioniert halt superklasse, wenn du halt einfach dann in deine Google-Account-Daten eingibst und dann...
Und den ganzen Opt-in da einfach da alles...
Und den ganzen Opt-in da einfach machst du mit deinem Kalender und dann sinkt das halt alle und irgendwie alle E-Mails sind da und du kannst dann Dokumente sinken und... Funktioniert alles super fluffig, genauso ist das halt mit diesem Dot-Neck- oder Mobile-Me-Zeug, ist halt genau dasselbe Spiel. Und interessant ist ja, dass aber offensichtlich Apple da einfach die Sitten verdirbt, weil die... also Microsoft macht jetzt genau dasselbe mit dem...
Microsoft hat das auch schon länger versucht, glaub ich. Also dieses Live-Zeug, was die da seit ein paar Jahren pushen.
Das tut mir nicht angekommen.
Nein, aber das ist auch so was. Also die haben sogar jetzt ihr Office nach Web portiert. Das ist zwar irgendwie eine abgespeckte Version, aber die sind auch richtig bereit, da wo sie ihre Kerne Einnahmen herholen, das ins Web zu tun, nur damit die Leute auf ihre Plattformen springen. Und das ist deutlich schon so, dass Microsoft sieht, dass da quasi die Zukunft vom Internet hingeht. Sonst machen die den Großteil ihrer Einnahmen mit Windows und Office. Und das ist eigentlich nicht einzusehen, warum man jetzt Office verschenken sollte.
Sonst ein eigener Fleischnain sozusagen.
Aber dass sie es tun, ist eigentlich nur damit zu erklären, dass sie quasi demonstrieren wollen, dass man auch mit anderen Systemen mit ihnen interagieren kann. Und das sieht Apple ja nicht so. Also Apple hat kein Problem, ihr zu sagen, hier iTunes gibt es halt für Windows und Linux, scheißen wir drauf. Das hätte man ja auch alles browserbasiert machen können, mit offenen Standards.
Na gut, ich meine, iTunes ist nun selbst in den Augen von hartgesotten Mac-Fanboys, ist iTunes irgendwie die schwere, ne eitrige Wunde.
Oh echt? Sie dachten, sie sagten, sie so haben das Support, mir das dann...
Naja, weil es halt irgendwie gerade funktioniert mit dem Podcast. Das ist halt der einfachste Weg, auf dein iPod einen Podcast drauf zu bekommen. Aber tatsächlich ist diese Software eine große, schwere, gelbe Wunde. Es ist halt irgendwie nicht schön so, die ist halt langsam. Wenn du da auf viele Fails rein tust, dann macht es merkwürdige Dinge. Und die Nutzungsentschränkungen sind halt irgendwie schon enorm. Also es ist halt so, dass da halt auch momentan gerade Apple ganz schön Kritik einsteckt. Interessant fand ich ja dieses Urteil in Amiland, dass es jetzt legal ist, ein iPhone zu jailbreaken.
genau, das hat uns gefreut. Eigentlich ist es vorher schon klar gewesen. Also die gesetzlichen Regelungen waren eigentlich vorher schon relativ deutlich. Aber der Zeitgeist ging halt in die andere Richtung. Und so hat uns er sehr gefreut, dass die Richter das jetzt beschlossen haben und offen gesagt haben. Und was wir bei der Gelegenheit mal ansagen können, in Deutschland gilt das auch. Also auch hier, jailbreaking von Phones, legal. Wer das Phone kauft, darf es umgehen. Man darf sogar Software reverse-ingenieren in Deutschland.
Zum Zweck der Kompatibilität.
genau. Das heißt, wenn man möchte, dass die Daten mit einem anderen Gerät zusammenarbeiten, was ja normalerweise auch der Hintergrund von so was ist, das ist explizit erlaubt in Deutschland.
Interessant ist ja, was das jetzt für die anderen Hersteller bedeutet. Weil sowohl Microsoft mit dem neuen Windows Phone 7 hat ja so einen ähnlichen Ansatz, irgendwie alles zuzunageln. Die Android-Devices, die man so normal kaufen kann, jetzt nachdem Google das Nexus One plattgemacht hat, weil das einzige Device war, wo man halt Ruht drauf hatte, ohne sich aufzubeißen. Also das heißt, diesen Trend, den Apple ja gesetzt hat, also die Telefone, die HM-Telefone als Closed System zu machen, wo man keine Kontrolle drüber hat und wo man selber zwar Telefon kaufen darf, aber wem es halt gehört, nämlich dem Hersteller de facto, dass man da keinen Anfluss drauf hat. Das könnte mit diesem Urteil jetzt auch ein bisschen im allgemeinen Bewusstsein kippen. Und das ist ja genau der Punkt, nämlich genau die Frage, was sind die allgemeine Ansicht zu diesem Thema. Und solange die Leute halt der Meinung sind, dass das schon okay ist, dass sie sich da ein Telefon kaufen, das gehört eigentlich aber Apple oder Google und nicht ihnen. Weil jetzt also die tatsächliche Ownership der Software angeht, wird sich doch wenig ändern. Aber wenn es jetzt losgeht, zum Beispiel, dass das Trailbreaking legal wird, dann ändert sich das.
Das ist ja ein Problem, was genau so eigentlich auf alle möglichen Bereiche des Lebens zutrifft. Also die Frage stellt sich auch zum Beispiel bei den Bahngleisen. Die haben wir finanziert. Gehören die uns eigentlich oder darf der Staat es jetzt an die Bahn verschenken? Das ist ja eigentlich im übertragenden Sinne dieselbe Problematik. Oder mit dem Internet. Net-N-Traility ist ja auch im Grunde dieselbe Problematik. Wir haben hier ein Internet gebaut und bezahlt und dürfen jetzt die Leute da quasi das kaputt machen, um mehr Profit zu machen. Gehört mir das Internet, was ich mit aufgebaut und bezahlt habe, oder gehört das zu irgendwelchen Konzernen? Und das ist eine Sache, die wir als Netzbewohner und natürlich auch wir als CCC auf die Agenda setzen müssen. Das hängt an uns.
Also nicht nur Net Neutrality, sondern auch Device Neutrality.
genau, gehören unsere Devices uns, oder gehören die Vodafone oder T-Mobile?
Oder Google oder Apple.
Oder wie machen wir?
genau. Ich denke mal, das ist ein Thema, was uns noch die nächste Zeit beschäftigen wird. Also totalitäres Verhalten ist ja nun nicht die Ursprungsdomäne von Konzernen. Die waren ja früher immer ein bisschen anders, sondern eigentlich sind es ja Regierungen, die sich da bisher am weitesten hervorgetan haben. Gerade mal wieder ist die US-Regierung da ganz weit vorne. Ich weiß noch nicht, was die meisten Leute jetzt mitbekommen haben. Wikileaks war ja so einige Zeit ziemlich down und irgendwie sah ein bisschen kaputt aus und so und hatte irgendwie ziemlich Kritik einstecken müssen. Dann haben sie jetzt eine ziemliche Krache gezündet und haben einige 10.000 interne Berichte der US-Armee aus Afghanistan publiziert. Und zusammen mit zum ersten Mal internationalen Medienorganisationen, also was war es? Spiegel? genau. Und von denen sozusagen die Analyse kam, während Wikileaks heute nur die Rodaten publiziert hat. Und dann waren die Reaktionen der amerikanischen Regierung sehr interessant. Da gab es eine Pressekonferenz von dem Pressesprecher des Weißen hauses. Und da gab es auch einen so einen Satz drin, der mich echt so ein bisschen schlussig gemacht hat. Und zwar hat er was dazu gesagt, was denn die US-Regierung getan hätte, wenn jetzt nicht Wikileaks diese Daten rausgetan hätte, sondern nur die New York Times. Und der sagte halt, naja, also wenn es nur die New York Times gewesen wäre, dann hätten wir sicherlich uns irgendwie Mühe gegeben und da ein bisschen Aufwand investiert, um zu verhindern, dass die New York Times diese Daten publiziert. Das heißt also, da sieht man mal wieder, dass also tatsächlich dieses Publizieren der Rohdaten die Medienorganisationen dazu zwingt, eben die Story zu bringen und nicht nur wieder aufzusitzen, wie es ja schon so oft der Fall war.
Naja, es ist noch ein bisschen mehr. Also ich glaube, das können wir tatsächlich Wikileaks umhängen, den Orden. Denn die haben nicht nur mit mehreren gesprochen, sondern sie haben von Anfang an gesagt, wir reden mit mehreren, auch international. Und wenn ihr das nicht nehmt, nehmt es halt ein anderer. Denn wenn man in der Vergangenheit guckt, mit ähnlichen Fällen wie zum Beispiel den Pentagon Papers, Daniel Ellsberg, oder mit den mit Watergate. Und also das ist in der Geschichte des Journalismus immer wieder so gewesen, dass die New York Times in Amerika jetzt, dass die New York Times und die Washington Post so ein halbes Jahr auf solchen Sachen gesessen haben.
Oder auch mal ein Jahr.
Oder ein Jahr.
Aber die Abu-Ghraib-Geschichten waren ja auch in der Öffentlichkeit.
genau, die Abu-Ghraib-Geschichten, da haben die gesamten Medien in den USA ein Jahr drauf gesessen. Und normal, also das ist auch kein Alleingang der USA, dass die Regierung so eine Terrorkarte ziehen kann und dann die Medien zensiert.
Die National-Security-Karte ist es ja, oder?
genau, die National-Security-Karte ist es. Die Briten haben sowas auch. Und auch bei uns gibt es sowas.
Bei den Briten ist es ja noch sehr viel expliziter. Da gibt es die sogenannten Denotes. Das ist also eine Methode, mit der der Premierminister die Chefredakteure, offiziell heißt es glaube ich heutzutage bitten, früher war es tatsächlich anordnen kann, über bestimmte Themen nicht zu berichten. Und die halten sich da natürlich auch alle dran. Und früher waren es halt Sachen National Security-Geschichten. In Israel zum Beispiel ist das auch noch sehr offiziell. Da gibt es eine Zensurbehörde. Eine Militärzensur, die lustige Image-Kampagnen macht, nach dem Motto, wir zensieren ja gar nicht so doll, sondern nur so ein bisschen. Und alle Menschen, die hier arbeiten, sind junge, hübsche, intelligente frauen, die das gar nicht böse meinen, sondern halt nur...
genau, die haben eine wunderbare Geschichte beim ehemaligen Nachrichtenmagazin publiziert.
Ja, mit dem Interview mit der Chefin, der Zensurbehörde.
genau, die ist eine Chefin, das ist ja schon mal immer gut in Deutschland. Das wissen wir spätestens seit den geliegten Pentagon-Papieren, wie man mit Afghanistan umgehen soll, in denen es nämlich hieß, man muss zeigen die afghanischen frauen.
Hast du den Times-Titel gesehen heute?
Ja, den habe ich gesehen, aber das, finde ich, zählt nicht, weil die Times ist ja eine US-Zeit, und das bezog sich explizit auf Deutschland.
Ach so, aber da trotzdem passt es ja genau.
Aber es passt natürlich nicht an das Schema. Na klar, und ich denke, das funktioniert auch in anderen Ländern.
Also der Times-Titel war halt, um es nochmal zu erklären, was passiert, wenn wir aus Afghanistan abziehen, und beschreibt dann haltet Leid der frauen da unter den Taliban. Was natürlich eine vollkommen berechtigte Frage ist. Die muss man halt auch stellen. Nur in diesem Kontext ist es halt so, dass die doch schon sehr danach roch, als wenn es sich dabei um eine bestellte Propagandageschichte handelt, um halt diese Wikileaks-Geschichte zu contenten.
überhaupt Wikileaks, also es ist so ein bisschen, das finde ich immer sehr instruktiv, zu beobachten, wie so Leute in Panik reagieren. Denn wenn so eine Nachricht neu rauskommt, wie mit Wikileaks, das ist jetzt zwar nicht völlig überraschend, aber trotzdem ist es eine Situation, die die Pressesprecher, die Regierung nicht unter Kontrolle haben, im Gegensatz zu den meisten anderen Situationen, mit denen die zu arbeiten haben. Das heißt, da hat man so ein bisschen das Verhalten, wie so ein Reh auf der Straße, solange dann noch das Fernlicht in die Augen strahlt, sind die durchaus, machen die Fehler. Und das ist immer sehr interessant nach irgendwelchen Katastrophen oder nach irgendwelchen unvorhergesehenen Situationen zu beobachten, wie die sich in Widersprüche verwickeln.
Am schönsten war ja Gutenberg, also unser Verteidigungsminister. Gutenberg, ja. Gutenberg, der übernahm halt erstmal die Linie von den Amis, weil es ist halt alles old news und kennen wir ja schon. Und verstieg sich dann zu der bemerkenswerten Aussage. Also alles, was da drin steht, hatte er ja den den Fraktions-Obleuten im Bundestag schon lange gesagt.
Aber die hätten es nicht weiter sagen dürfen.
Die hätten es natürlich auf Sicherheitsgründe nicht weiter sagen dürfen. So und Zitat aus dem Spiegel. Er rate den Obleuten bei solchen Unterrichtungen, Zitat, dann auch wach zu sein und entsprechend zuzuhören.
Das lässt ja tief blicken. Ja, genau so wie man sich den Bundestag vorstellt.
Also ich will ja nicht mal ausschließen, dass er sogar Recht hat.
Natürlich hat er Recht.
Dass die das jetzt nicht binden.
Verständlich, das ist ein Mittagsschläfchen. Wenn du eh nicht darüber reden darfst, dann bist du nie in der Verlegenheit, dass dich jemand zur Rechenschaft ziehen kann, weil du nicht aufgepasst hast.
Stimmt.
Das heißt, das ist die perfekte Gelegenheit, noch mal ein Schläfchen anzulegen. Ein bisschen Porn zu klicken oder ein Mittagsschläfchen zu machen. Das sind ja nicht nur die Fehler und Widersprüche, in die die sich verwickeln in solchen Fällen, sondern als Außenstehler kann man auch sehr gut beobachten, wie sich die Strategie entwickelt. Am Anfang ist eben noch so was, machen wir jetzt. Dann ist erst mal leugnen, denn normalerweise das klappt natürlich nicht, wenn Wikileaks die Dokumente auf den Tisch getan hat. Aber da kommen dann so Sachen wie, naja, das wussten wir doch alles schon.
genau, das ist alles old news.
Das war der erste Vorwurf, das kennen wir alles schon.
genau, die zweite Linie ist jetzt irgendwie, Wikileaks hat ja Blut an den Händen.
genau, das ist besonders apart, weil das von den Leuten kommt, die beruflich die Aufgabe haben, Leute umzubringen. Wenn also Soldaten anderen, den Betreiber einer Webseite vorwirft, er habe Blut an den Händen, da weiß ich dann auch nicht mehr, was man da noch groß kommentieren soll. Also das ist irgendwie selbst verlinkt.
Ich hatte noch nicht so viel Zeit, die Nachrichten durchzugucken, nur so ein bisschen gezielt nach ein paar Sachen gesucht da drin. Interessant war diese Geschichte mit den Surface-to-Air-Missiles, die in Amingland auch relativ viele Wogen geschlagen hat. Also in zwar geht es darum, die Taliban, die ja so genetisch von den Mujahideen in Afghanistan abstammen, also den Leuten, die die Amerikaner damals gesponsert haben, um die Russen...
Die Terrorzelle der Amerikaner gegen die Russen.
Die Terrorzelle, also der Übergang zwischen Freiheitskämpfern und Terroristen ist natürlich immer sehr fließend. Also nachdem jetzt nun diese Taliban halt den Übergang von Freiheitskämpfern zu Terroristen gemacht haben, stellt sich offenbar raus, dass sie noch so ein paar von den Surface-to-Air-Missiles, also so kleine, schultergetragene Raketen, mit denen man hubschraubern und Flugzeuge abschießen kann, von damals entweder behalten haben, was ich nicht glaube, die wären auch irgendwann schlecht, glaube ich, oder irgendwo andersherberiche haben.
Also wir sollten vielleicht kurz die Geschichte erläutern, wie überhaupt diese Raketen dahin kamen. Das ging nämlich damals los, dass Russland Afghanistan angreifen wollte. Das haben die Amerikaner relativ geschickt eingeleitet, dass sie quasi das so gemacht haben, dass sie wollten den Russen ihr eigenes Vietnam geben. Das war irgendwie das Ziel damals. Und sie haben sich halt überlegt, sie müssen die Russen dazu bringen, dass sie das Land quasi verteidigen wollen und dass sie ihnen eine Freiheitskämpfer-Mujahideen-Welle entgegensetzen und haben den Mujahideen dann eben Waffen gegeben. Und die haben sie finanziert mit Drogenschmuggel aus Südamerika.
Unter anderem, es gibt da diesen wirklich großartigen Film Charlie Willsons War.
Da geht es genau darin.
Der ist einer der besten, also eigentlich so in meiner Liste von amerikanischen politischen Filmen, so ziemlich direkt nach Wake the Dog, das ist der andere, ein wirklich großartiger Film. In Charlie Willsons War geht es darum, um Charlie Willson, einen amerikanischen Senator aus Texas, der mit Hilfe von christlichen Fundis aus Texas die Finanzierung für die Mujahideen da bewerkstelligt hat. Und die Amerikaner haben damals, um gegen die Russen zu gewinnen, also die Sowjets damals, den Mujahideen diese Luftabwehrraketen zukommen lassen, Stinger Missiles heißen die. Also Stinger ist der Grundnahme für diese Raketen. Da gibt es noch ein paar andere, aber man nennt sie meistens als Stinger. Und damit haben sie dann...
Also ManPad heißen sie offiziell, ne?
genau, ManPad ist die Abkürzung für......Shoulder launched, irgendwie, für NTR-Missile. Ja, irgendwie sowas.
Also der Trick bei den Teilen ist, dass es eben die billigen sind, die keine elektronische Fernsteuerung haben, sondern die schießt man förmlich los. Und die sind damit auch nicht wirklich jambar. Also der Angriff gegen die meisten von diesen Raketen, die man von hubschraubern oder so abschießt.
Also die originalen Stinger Missiles waren Hitziker. Also Hitze suchen Raketen, die auf die Hitze von den Triebwerken gingen. Das funktioniert so, da ist halt ein Infrarot-Sensor drin und die Rakete rotiert. Und man versucht den durch Steuerung des Triebwerks, also des Abgasstrahls, dafür zu sorgen, dass die Hitzequelle, die man initial angepeilt hat mit der Rakete, immer in der Mitte des Hitzesuchers ist. Und die haben, also die originalen Stinger haben eine relativ, also nach heutigen Maßstäben haben die, glaube ich, so 0,4 Prozent. Also die Trefferratio ist, glaube ich, 40 Prozent.
Das ist ja nicht schlecht. Also das Rotieren ist aber wegen Stabilität eigentlich.
genau, also es gibt halt mehrere Methoden, wie man das lenken kann. Und wenn du rotierst, brauchst du nur eine Lenkflosse. Weil wenn du dann weißt, wie du rotiert bist, dann kannst du halt den Abgasstrahl durch eben kippen des Lenkruders ändern. Und also es funktioniert halt so, du hältst das Ding halt auf den hubschrauber oder auf das Flugzeug, oder was immer du anpeilen willst. Und wenn der Sensor eine Hitzequelle gefunden hat, dann biebt er. Und wenn du also den Düth hörst, dann ziehst du den Abzug und dann bleibt er auf der Hitzequelle. Und dann gibt es halt irgendwie so ein paar Einstellungen, die halt total sind. Die Waffe ist darauf optimiert, also die originalen Stinger, dass sie wirklich von bauern bedient werden kann. Also das Training, was du dafür brauchst, ist so ultraminimal. Das ist einfach nur, sieh zu, dass das Flugzeug in diesem Viereck ist. Wenn es so und so weit weg ist, dann musst du noch einen anderen Viereck hochklappen und ansonsten gibt es noch einen Batterietest-Taster und irgendwie muss es biepen. Und dann kannst du abzunehmen. Die Manuals zu den originalen Stingers findet man auch im Web. Also die kann man aussuchen. Das ist durchaus instruktiv. Nun ja, stellt sich also raus, dass den Wikileaks Report, dass offensichtlich die Taliban, also die Ex-Motor Ideen, entweder neue von diesen Dingern akquiriert haben oder noch Altbestände hatten. Jedenfalls haben sie da offensichtlich hubschrauber mit abgeschossen. Und die Amerikaner haben zumindest in einem dieser Fälle erklärt, dass der Abschuss eben nicht mit so einer Surface-to-Air-Messer, also mit so einer schultergestützten Luftabwehrraketen...
Also nicht mit einer Rakete, sondern sie haben gesagt Rocket-Propelled Grenade.
genau.
Das ist eher so ein...
Eine panzerfaust.
genau. Und das ist echt schwer vorzustellen, dass jemand aus der Ferne... Also wenn der so drei Meter von dir entfernt ist, da kannst du das...
Also der Punkt ist, dass das tatsächlich passiert ist. Und zwar in Somalia. Und zwar dieser Film Black Hawk Down, also das Buch dazu ist eigentlich besser als der Film, da ist genau das passiert. Was die da getan haben, ist, die haben in der Innenstadt da gewartet, bis ein hubschrauber über so einer kleinen LA stand und dann von unten halt mit der panzerfaust draufgeschossen. Und basierend darauf, dass alle das wussten, dass das geht, und wenn es auch extrem unwahrscheinlich ist, aber alle haben es in Black Hawk Down gesehen, dass es funktioniert, haben die Amis gesagt, doch, naja, dann behaupten wir halt einfach, es ist eine RPG, weil dann haben wir da weniger Stress, dann müssen wir nicht dem Kongress erklären, wieso jetzt die Mujahideen, Al-Di-Taliban plötzlich schon wieder Stinger Missiles oder ähnliches Zeug haben.
Also es gab vor ein paar Jahren aus Afghanistan einen großartigen Bericht, wo es darum ging, dass die, also das ist ja, ist zwar mit Drogengeldern bezahlt worden, aber es gab trotzdem Accounting darüber natürlich. Und den Amerikanern ist halt aufgefallen, dass die da viel mehr von Instingern rein liefern mussten, als dann tatsächlich benutzt wurden. Und als sie nachgeforscht haben, ist dann halt rausgekommen, dass es über drei, vier Mittelsmänner ging, halt die Warlords in der Region. Und die haben von allen Einkommenden Waffenlieferungen erst mal die Hälfte irgendwo vergraben, für harte Zeiten. Und das heißt, das gesamte Land ist quasi voller geheimer Waffencaches. Und dementsprechend sind auch alle alle Ansagen von wegen, wir müssen die Grenzen zu machen, damit da nicht mehr Waffen reinkommen. Völlig lächerlich. Also Afghanistan zu entwaffnen, kann man vergessen. Lustigerweise haben die Amerikaner Probleme mit dem Nachschub. Gar nicht mal an den Waffen, sondern an Munition. Also da gab es die großartige Story 2006, dass die Amerikaner für ihre Armee keine Gewehrmunition mehr hatten und nachbestellen mussten. Und weil die die Zufahrtsrouten alle selbst umkämpft waren, also Irak, Iran war ein bisschen schwierig, und auch die Anrichtung Pakistan ist ja auch nicht gerade ein ruhiges Gebiet, da haben sie sich an die Russen gewandt. Und da gibt es halt diesen Bericht von dem zuständigen russischen Waffenschieberdiplomaten, der lachend vom Stuhl gefallen sein soll, als er das gehört hat. Weil er dachte, das ist ein Witz, dass die für 400 Millionen Munitionen von ihnen kaufen wollen. Also das ist historisch gesehen alles eine wunderbare Ironie, von der es sich wirklich lohnt, da mal ein bisschen hinterherzulesen, weil das ist echt sehr erheiternd.
Na ja, spannend ist ja, dass die Bestandteil des großen Deals, den die Russen gerade offen mit den Amerikanern machen, ja unter anderem ist, dass sie die Logistik durch Russland durchmachen können. Also dass sie halt das russische Eisenbahnnetz benutzen können, um da ihre Logistikprobleme zu lösen, weil ihnen Pakistan also nachher noch um die Ohren fliegt.
Und da geht es auch um Öl übrigens, es geht nicht nur um eine Ölpipeline. Und Russland hat auch Interesse daran, sich in Ölpipelines in der Gegend einzukaufen.
Aber ich glaube, Ölpipelines müssen wir nochmal eine gesonderte Sache zeigen.
Die gesamte Gegend ist sehr interessant. Und es gab auch die Verschwörungstheorie, dass der Afghanistankrieg überhaupt nur losgetreten wurde, weil sie da eine Pipeline bauen wollten.
Die war ja von 2004, 2005 oder so.
Das ist schon eine Weile her.
Aber ich glaube, zu Pipelines machen wir nochmal eine Extra-Sendung.
Zu Pipelines machen wir nochmal eine Extra-Sendung. Aber die gesamte Gegend, die Kriegsführung da, ist im Grunde hauptsächlich ein logistisches Problem. Weil es echt schwierig ist, da einen Nachschub herzuholen.
Also noch so eine andere Geschichte, die mir an diesen Wikileaks-Nachrichten aufgefallen ist, sind die Unmengen von Inzidenz, wo ihnen Drohnen runtergefallen sind. Also sie haben ja immer gesagt, okay, mit den Drohnen können wir halt irgendwie sehr viel mehr Cover-It- erzielen. Das heißt, wir haben halt viel mehr Möglichkeiten, da irgendwas in der Luft zu haben, was zumindest beobachtet oder uns halt für Bomben schmeißt. Und in den Nachrichten, wo man da halt sucht nach den Typenbezeichnungen von so den gängigen Drohnen, findet man eine ganze Menge, wo die runtergefallen sind. Und jedes Mal, wenn die runterfallen, dann müssen die halt...
Dann müssen die eingesammelt werden....
eingesammelt oder vernichtet werden. Und wenn die halt in echt schwierigen Gebieten runterfallen, wo diese Amis sonst halt nicht so viel Abdeckung haben an Truppen, da müssen sie halt...
Was ja auch die Idee ist von den Drohnen, genau damit sie sie hinschicken.
Dann müssen sie da halt Special Forces hinschicken, um die Dinger einzusammeln oder zu sprengen. Oder halt, wenn es überhaupt gar nicht anders geht, sie halt irgendwie bombardieren zu lassen.
Mir fällt gerade diese Geschichte ein, als die Bundeswehr in Afghanistan eine Drohne einsetzen wollte, erinnerst du dich?
Diese Luna, ja.
Sie haben eine Drohne, das war eine gekaufte israelische Drohne, die haben sie da eingeflogen und die ist ihnen auf dem Flugplatz mit einer Herkules-Maschine kollidiert und war total schaden. Also das war immer wieder so eine Aktion, die Bundeswehr super.
Zum Bundeswehr habe ich noch gar nicht geguckt, wie viel da in den Nachrichten drin ist. Ich hatte mir nur irgendwie die Meldung zu dem...
Ich denke mal als Eishäfter und nicht so direkt als Bundeswehr. Oder so Germans.
Zu dem Kundesinzident, den hatte ich mir irgendwie nur kurz angeguckt und die Meldung war aber wieder mal völlig nichtssagend. Aber die, naja, also die Sache mit den Drohnen ist ja so ein universelles Phänomen. Die deutsche Polizei würde ja auch gerne Drohnen haben.
Also wollen sie Drohnen haben. Aber ich meine, man muss sich auch fragen, ist das nicht die Idee, warum man Drohnen einsetzt? Weil es besser ist, wenn die da runterkommen, als wenn die gleich ein F-16 absturzt?
Naja, also es gibt mehrere Gründe für Drohnen. Der wichtigste ist, dass sie sehr viel länger in der Luft bleiben können. Also ein Pilot muss halt irgendwann pinkeln. Es gibt zwar irgendwie...
Die werden ferngesteuert aus Nevada, habe ich gedacht.
Ja, viele von denen werden über einen Satelliten ferngesteuert.
Allein, was die Latenz da ist...
Nein, du fliegst hier nicht, sondern du setzt ein paar Waypoints.
genau, aber im Grunde finde ich das schon echt unglaublich. Also technologisch gesehen, dass du aus Nevada, aus irgendeinem Data Center, da eine Drohne über Afghanistan steuerst und da den Live-Feed kriegst.
Und zwar nicht ganz wenige, sondern richtig viele. Und wieso die Polizei halt Drohnen haben will, ist, dass die Flugstunden sehr viel billiger sind, weil die Dinger sind halt sehr klein im Vergleich zu normalen Flugzeugen oder gar zu hubschraubern. hubschraubern kosten ja einen Höllen Geld pro Flugstunde. Und die deutsche Polizei zum Beispiel hat halt häufiger tatsächlich hubschrauber nur oben, um da zu viel, also um halt einfach da ein Bild von oben zu haben und die wollen...
Weil das ist schon eine andere Drohnenklasse auch. Also die setzen eher so diese Quadcopter ein, ne?
Ja, die haben jetzt diese Quadcopter. Für die anderen kriegen sie halt irgendwie auch keine Genehmigung. Also das Problem ist halt mit diesen Drohnen. Die kann man halt nicht zuverlässig in das normale Airspace Management einbinden. Also es gibt halt keine Regeln, keine sinnvollen Standards dafür, wie man dafür sorgt, dass die halt nicht in ein Flugzeug ranfliegen und dass man den Piloten erreicht oder wie auch immer.
Na, man könnte die Höhe limitieren, ne?
Das versuchen sie halt. Also diese Quadcopter zum Beispiel, die können nur bis 300 Meter fliegen, was und ab. Da fängt halt der regulierte Airspace an, ne?
genau, das ist dann so wie Drachensteigen. Also man sollte vielleicht sagen, die Drohnen, die da hin... Ne, die Drohnen, recht. Die Drohnen, die in Afghanistan fliegen, die sehen schon eher wie richtige Flugzeuge aus. Also zwar ohne innenraum, aber von der Linie her. Ja, die sind ja schon richtig aus groß.
Die fliegen da auch ganz klein. Also gibt da diese Raven zum Beispiel, oder noch kleiner. Die sind so mehr oder minder Modellflugzeuge.
Wie hießen denn diese israelischen Teile nochmal?
Die heißen Reaper die auch.
genau.
Also gibt aber die... Ne, Heron heißen die, entschuldigung. Heron ist der Hersteller. Reaper sind die Predator-Nachfolger.
genau, da gibt es nämlich schöne Bilder auf Google Images. Und da sieht man, dass die schon durchaus groß genug sind, dass ein Pilot daneben steht und ähnlich hoch ist. Also die sind nicht so klein.
Ne. Die britische Polizei wäre genauso was. Die hat ja esrätische Drohnen gekauft und...
Was war das eigentlich, was die Schweizer eingesetzt haben gegen ihre Kiffer?
Ich glaube, die Schweizer haben diese kleinen hubschrauber oder, ne, die Schweizer haben eine eigene Drohne. Die haben auch so mittelgroße Flugzeugdrohnen, also die so ein bisschen kleiner als die Chesna sind. Na ja, die deutsche Polizei und ihre Videotechnik ist natürlich immer so ein Thema. Gerade wurde ja die anlasslose Videoüberwachung auf Demonstrationen legalisiert. Also die...
Illegalisiert.
genau ausbrechen. Illegalisiert.
Richtig.
Also wir hatten es ja zuletzt bei dieser Freiheit statt Angst Demo-Geschichte, dass wir da immer wieder gesehen haben, dass wenn die den gefilmt haben, dann haben sie immer schön gleich wieder weggeguckt, wenn es um Polizeigewalt ging.
Also die Vermutung haben wir ja schon länger gehabt. Aber bei der Freiheit statt Angst Demo haben wir es halt gesehen. Da haben wir halt diesen Incident gehabt, als ein paar Polizisten einen Demonstranten zusammengeschlagen haben. Und den gab es halt aus zehn Winkeln. Davon acht von Passanten und zwei von der Polizei. Und die haben genau weggeguckt, wenn es gerade darum ging, den zu verhauen. Also das konnte man echt sehen, dass der Typ, der die Kamera gehalten hat, sich bemüht hat, nicht zu filmen, keine Beweise gegen Kollegen zu haben.
Und interessant ist jetzt aber, dass der Berliner Polizeipräsident, der Herr Glitsch, den Namen sollte man sich merken, der findet dieses Gerichtsurteil so scheiße, dass er sofort gefordert hat, dass es ein Gesetz geben muss. Und auch gesagt hat, er wird halt weiter Demonstrationen videoüberwachen lassen, weil er sieht halt keine andere Möglichkeit. Und hat sich dann tatsächlich dazu verstiegen, diesen schrecklichen Unfall auf der Loveparade, oder man kann auch dieses schreckliche Organisationsverbrechen auf der Loveparade sagen, als Begründung heranzuziehen, warum sie weiter Videoüberwachung anlasslos brauchen, weil sonst könnten sie sowas ja nicht verhindern.
Was besonders krass ist, wenn man sich überlegt, dass es auf der Loveparade ja diese Überwachung gab. Die Bilder sind gerade heute in den Medien veröffentlicht worden und da sieht man, die haben eine gute Überwachung gehabt und haben es trotzdem nicht verhindert. Also das ist so auf jeder nur denkbaren Ebene ist dieses Argument unglaublich.
Diese Loveparade-Geschichte, ich habe ja irgendwie eine Weile nichts zu geschrieben, weil ich halt irgendwie, naja, ich fand es irgendwie ganz schön schrecklich. Aber als dann das Innenministerium NRW diese Bilder und die Karten publiziert hat, da fiel mir dann aber auch nichts mehr zu ein.
Hast du doch was geschrieben?
Ja, ich habe im Blog ein bisschen was dazu geschrieben, weil die haben ja tatsächlich die Menschenströme dagegenläufig durchgeschickt.
Das ging, glaube ich, auch nicht anders, weil das der einzige Einige ist, der auch vorher ungeschickt ist.
Ja, da geht eine fette Autobahn daneben. Die wollten sie halt nicht machen, weil sie zu teuer war, eine Rampe zu bauen. Die Autobahn war gesperrt zu der Zeit, d.h. die war frei.
Ach nee.
Ja, und das war ihnen nur zu teuer. Das kam dann später raus, das war ihnen zu teuer, auf der Karte ist da ein Gelb zu sehen. Das war ihnen zu teuer, die Rampen zu bauen, damit die Leute am hauptbahnhof auf die Autobahn kommen und von der Autobahn aufs Gelände kommen. Da hätten sie halt große Rampen bauen müssen. Und die waren der Stadt zu teuer, und deswegen haben sie halt diesen Morgs da gemacht. So mit irgendwie Leute gegenläufig da irgendwie in diese Tunnel schicken. Und man muss sich vor allem mal überlegen, deutsche Wissenschaftler waren diejenigen, die als ein Necker, die so schrecklichen Geschichten passiert sind, wo diverse hundert Leute umgekommen sind. Dann haben deutsche Wissenschaftler dafür gesorgt, dass das halt wesentlich glimpflicher abgeht.
Flowmanagement.
Dann haben wir Control-Control und Flowmanagement gemacht. Dann haben wir halt richtig lange daran rumingeniert und daran rumgeforscht.
Was übrigens ein echt cooler Forschungsgegenstand ist. Also wer noch ein Forschungsgegenstand sucht für seine Karriere und richtig cooles Thema haben will, so Flowmanagement bei Menschenmassen ist ausgebaut und spannend. Aber naja, das zeigt mal wieder. Wir können, wenn wir wollen, aber wir wollen eigentlich nicht.
Also in Duisburg war ein klarer Fall von wir wollen nicht, sondern die wollten halt einfach nur möglichst billig diese große Einigkeit haben.
Das war auch eine Kommune und die Kommunen sind alle pleite bei uns.
Ja, dann hätten sie halt was überlegen müssen.
Ja, das Peinliche ist halt, dass sie dann für irgendwelche PR-Kampagnen doch Geld haben.
genau. Also die Berliner PR-Kampagnen ist auch an Peinlichkeit ja immer nicht zu überbieten. Ja. Wie Berlin, da fasst man sich nicht mehr viel zu ein. Interessant an der...
Da braucht man ein Facepalm-Geräusch fürs Radio.
Ja, die Geschichte bei der Loveparade war natürlich noch, da gab es ja erst diese Meldung, dass alle Einsatzdaten der Polizei gelöscht worden sein sollen.
Das hat der Spiegel geschrieben.
Angeblich wurde dann wieder dementiert und ging doch nicht so, oder?
Die Bundespolizei... Also, erst schrieb der Spiegel, die Bundespolizei habe alle ihre Daten gelöscht. Dann haben sie ein Update nachgeschoben. Sie wüssten es nur von einer Filiale. Und daraufhin, selbst das hat die Bundespolizei dann dementiert, hat gemeint, alles sei noch da und stünde zur Verfügung.
Okay.
Also, man weiß nicht...
Vielleicht war es nur eine Panikaktion von Panikern.
Ja, wahrscheinlich war das irgendwie eine Panikaktion.
Und interessant ist ja, dass sie die Ermittlungen an die Polizei Köln übergeben haben, weil sie sagten, naja, offensichtlich...
Das ist in der Tat ausgesprochen spannend, weil da frage ich mich, wieso hat eigentlich bei der Freiheit statt Angst, dem, wo die Staatsanwaltschaft Berlin......gegen die Polizei ermittelt?... die Polizei aus Berlin ermittelt? Das war doch klar, dass da nichts draus wird. Ja, wieso haben wir da nicht Brandenburg rangeholt? Und umgekehrt gibt es in Brandenburg sicher auch genug Fälle, wo die Berliner Staatsanwaltschaft mal...
Also eigentlich ist es eine gute Maßnahme.
Eigentlich sollte man das immer tun. Die Frage ist, ob Köln weit genug weg ist. Also bei Düsseldorf weiß man es, aber Düsseldorf?
Naja, werden wir sehen, denke ich mal.
Üblicherweise findet ihr ja eh nichts draus bei solchen Ermittlungen, weil die Polizisten halt nicht ausgezeichnet sind. Also bei welchem Thema?
Interessant ist ja, dass es da so viele Leute gab, die offensichtlich schon nur im Vorfall massiv unzufrieden waren. Also es könnte wohl sein, dass da Leute dann reden, weil es halt groß genug und schwerwiegend genug ist. Na hoffentlich erst mal. Wir hatten noch eine Eingabe von Amnesty International über Twitter. Wir haben letztes Mal ja darüber geredet, dass Amnesty fordert, Evidence Cams in Polizeigewahrsam einzurichten.
genau, was wir eigentlich eine gute Idee finden. Aber wo ich meinte, na ja, das ist bestimmt irgendwie in dem Moment, wo die Polizei sich selbst erwachen soll, kann man sich nicht darauf verlassen, dass das gibt. Und wer hat Amnesty zu geschrieben? Hat uns folgendes mitgeteilt.
Amnesty hat gesagt, also ihr Vorschlag ist, dass die Sichtung der Aufzeichnung nur nach Richterbeschluss durch eine berechtigte Ermittlungsinstanz stattfindet, was uns ja wieder zu der Frage zurückbringt, wer ist denn die Ermittlungsinstanz in solchen Fällen, also wenn es um Polizeigewalten und dergleichen Dinge geht, und die videoaufzeichnung muss für Polizeizugrufe und Manipulation geschützt sein, was ich technisch auch schon einigermaßen schwierig finde.
Also es gab halt Fälle, wo aus der Aserbatenkammer die offiziell eingepflegten Beweise, die Polizisten belastet haben, verschwunden sind. Und wo es dann heißt, ja, also das ist uns völlig unklar, wie das hätte passieren können.
Das ist ein technischer Fehler. Das ist wahrscheinlich bei der Festplatte von Franz Josef strauß.
genau.
genau. Also wie die technische Sicherung zu stellen ist, ist doch eine sehr interessante Frage.
Das ist natürlich einfach fordern kann man es schon mal, ne?
Also ich meine, es ist ja so, dass es gibt ja durchaus technische Mittel und Wege. Also zum Beispiel hat ja die Atomenergiebehörde, hat ja in Kernkraftwerken und anderen Installationen, haben die geschützte Kameras, die zumindest ein bisschen schwieriger zu manipulieren sind. Also wahrscheinlich ist das für einen Nationalstaat, der eine Atombombe bauen will, halt auch nicht so ein großes Problem, diese Kameras irgendwie zu manipulieren. Aber sie haben sich da schon echt Mühe gegeben, diese Dinger zu...
Das war ein verplompt und macht einen verschlüsselten Strom, oder?
Ja, und irgendwie mit irgendwie Detection, ob dann Spiegel davor ist und irgendwie so...
Oh echt? Wie erkennt man das denn?
Beheizt, ich weiß nicht, die Details nicht. Aber sie machen halt irgendwie echt eine Menge Fu. Also die Dinger sind auch nicht billig. Und die Kameras sind auch eher unförmig groß. Also es ist halt schon so, dass die...
Das klingt ja spannend.
Die trägt man nicht so richtig weg. Aber da finden wir vielleicht auch noch mal einen Experten, der uns dazu weiter erzählen kann. Jedenfalls, so was geht natürlich schon. Aber die Frage ist dann halt, ob es denn von den entscheidenden...
Auf dem Dorf.
Den entscheidenden Momenten halt eben Bilder gibt. Also im Zweifel ist, dann machen die dann halt den alten Trick von der Stasi. Die haben ja, wenn sie verhindern wollten, dass gefilmt wird auf Demonstrationen in der DDR, dann hatten sie dann immer so einen jungen Mann am Anorak, der eine Flasche Haarlack dabei hatte. Also durchsichtigen Haarlack. Und hat dann im Vorbeigehen kurz auf die Linse von der Kamera gemacht.
Und dann ist es unscharf, oder was passiert dann?
Na, man sieht dann halt nichts mehr, es ist nur noch die Helligkeit zu sehen. Und es sieht halt aus, als wenn die Linse unscharf geworden wäre. Also wenn du das schnell genug machst, dann sieht das nur aus, als wenn der Kameramann ein Trottel wäre. Aber nicht öfter.
Super, geht das von alleine weg?
Nee, das musst du dann putzen. Das ist dann schon richtig. Also die Linsencoating ist dann versaut.
Also ich habe nur die andere Variante gehört, wenn du quasi wolltest, dass die Leute in deine Richtung filmen, dass die Geheimdienste dann gerne mal ein paar nackte frauen rumtanzen lassen. Also heute habe ich es gelesen bei einem schönen Telepodis-Artikel von Markus Kompa zum Thema dieses russische U-Boot, was da verschwunden ist. Und da hieß es also, dass die Russen auch beobachten wollten, was die Amis da getan haben, die versucht haben, nämlich dieses U-Boot zu bergen.
Wir greifen gerade vor.
Wir greifen vor. Ich will nur auf das Detail hinaus, dass das eben Teil der Geschichte war, dass die Russen dann mit einem kleinen Beobachtungsboot sehr nah vorbeigefahren sind und da haben sich dann eben zwei unbekleidete frauen geräkelt. Und das ist eben eine Standardmethode bei Geheimdiensten. Angeblich taucht auch im Juretsko-Buch auf, als es darum ging, dass man eben wollte, wenn man die schon filmt, dass man auch ihre Gesichter frontal kriegt. genau. Und das ist also offenbar eine alte Methode und es leuchtet ja rein.
Ja, jetzt haben wir schon so ein bisschen bei den U-Booten auch so eine Geschichte, wo es gerade keine Bilder gibt, außer die Beule hinterher. In der Straße von Hormus ist ein japanischer Tanker, dem ist irgendwas wie der Farmlust dazu geführt, dass er eine sehr signifikante Beule nahe des Hecks hat. Und da gab es nun einige interessante Theorien, wie es nun dazu gekommen sein könnte. Und meine?
Also erst mal ging es mit Panik los, ne?
genau, ging erst mal mit Panik los, weil...
Erst hieß es Anschlag, Angriff.
genau, und das ist halt so die Straße von Hormus, muss man verstehen. Da geht ein richtig großer Teil des weltweiten Öltraffics durch. Also alles, was in den Golf-Anhörerstaaten gefördert wird, geht da durch. Es ist eine 35 Kilometer breite Wasserstraße, also nicht sehr breit.
Ein kleiner Hals des Golfs von Persiens Richtung Pazifik. Und da ist auf der einen Seite ist Dubai.
Auf der anderen Seite sind die arabischen Emirate und die und Oman ist noch so eine Ecke.
genau, aber halt Iran besitzt eben die eine Seite. Und das ist so die unausgesprochene Drohung immer. Wenn ihr einen Krieg mit dem Iran anfangt, dann holen die ihre Wasserminen raus und machen die Straße von Hormus zu.
Das gab es ja auch schon mal. Also es gab ja im Krieg Iran gegen Irak gab es ja die sogenannten Tanker Wars, wo die angefangen haben, die Tanker zu schießen und zwar direkt da in der Straße. Und die zu verminen. Gar nicht welche Seite es war. Müssen wir mal nachgucken, was ich glaube Irak war.
Also der Iran hat jedenfalls in Torpedos investiert seitdem.
genau, in Torpedos, Minen und Raketen, die gegen Schiffe, also an die Schiffraketen.
Sie haben auch Schnellboote, von denen sie dann zum Kapern. Was ja fast noch cooler ist, wenn du nämlich so ein riesen Tanker kaperst und den einfach da stehen lässt, dann ist nämlich zu. Das ist ein echt...
Nicht mal Kapern, also der...
Also ich meine, wenn du dafür sorgst, dass der halt nicht weiterfährt, sondern einfach da stehen bleibt, dann ist er zu. So ein super Tanker ist echt groß.
Den kriegst du doch nicht so ohne weiteres weg. Die Amis haben ja in ihren Wargames das ja mal versucht zu simulieren, was passiert, wenn die Iraner dann mit so ein paar hundert kleinen Schnellbooten versuchen, gegen die Flugzeugträger, Kampfgruppen loszugehen und haben dabei festgestellt, dass es dann wohl doch nicht so schön aussieht für die Amerikaner. Ich weiß nicht, ob sie mittlerweile was ausgedenkt haben.
Also diese Wargames, das sind Manöver, wo sie quasi beide Seiten mit amerikanischen Generellen besetzen und denen halt den Auftrag geben, also der amerikanische General soll halt die Strategie ausprobieren, die die Amerikaner eben vorgesehen haben. Und die andere Seite soll möglichst unkonventionell versuchen, darauf zu melden. genau, und diese Wargames gingen eigentlich alle so aus, dass die iranische Seite deutlich, deutlich Riesenverluste bei der Weltwirtschaft ausgelöst hat und das alles in den Keller ging. Und saudi Arabiens Ölexport geht zu über 80 Prozent durch die Straße von Hormus. Und das ist das billigste Öl, was es auf der Welt gibt. Also das heißt selbst, wenn man sagt, okay, wir können den Ausfall aus anderen Quellen decken, dann treibt es den Ölpreis derartig in die Höhe. Also das wäre total schaden, wenn die Straße von Hormus zugemacht wird, egal von wem.
So, und das erklärt jetzt so ein bisschen den Hintergrund, warum alle halt, wenn da an der Straße von Hormus was passiert, alle dann gleich anfangen irgendwie senkrecht in ihren Sitzen zu sitzen und echt nervös zu sein. Insofern war die erste Nachricht, da ist irgendwas explodiert. Es gab da wohl auch noch irgendeinen Blitz oder so zu derselben Zeit. Aber wenn man sich das mal so anguckt, die Delle da an dem Schiff, die sieht halt eher nach einer Kollision aus. Also die sieht eigentlich nicht aus wie...
Die kam so drei Tage später, das war nicht direkt verfügbar.
Und nun muss man wissen, also diese Straße von Hormus ist auch der einzige Weg, wie man U-Boote in den Golf reinbekommen und rausbekommen kann. Und von daher ist meine Theorie, dass eine Kollision mit einem U-Boot war. Weil die Standardtaktik, wenn man ein U-Boot durch so ein enges Gewässer bringen will, wo noch alle Seiten irgendwie Sonarsensoren drin haben und alle wissen wollen, welche U-Boote da rein und raus fahren, ist, sich direkt hinter so ein großes Schiff zu setzen und mit dem mitzufahren in derselben Geschwindigkeit. Und zwar wirklich ziemlich nah dran. Also nicht so 100 Meter weg oder so, sondern so wirklich nur so ein paar Dutzend Meter weg.
Im Windschatten direkt?
Direkt im Windschatten. Und damit auch im Geräuschschatten, weil dann kann man halt auch aufgetaucht fahren. Also mit dem Dieselmotor fahren, der sonst halt zu viel Geräusch macht. Und man ist im Radarschatten. Also so ein Supertanker macht halt ein riesiges Radarecho. Da sieht man den kleinen Turm von dem U-Boot überhaupt nicht. Und auch von dem Radar vom Schiff aus ist nicht zu sehen, weil das ist ja zwar oben auf dem Schiff, aber das Schiff selber, der sehr große Körper von dem Schiff, schattet halt auch hinrechen weit ab. Und deswegen ist es halt ein absolutes Standardmanöver für eigentlich alle U-Boot-Fahrer schon im Zweiten Weltkrieg gewesen, dass sie sich halt hinter so ein Frachter setzen, wenn sie halt zum Beispiel die Mähänge von Gibraltar wollen oder halt durch andere Gegenden oder wenn die Amerikaner zum Beispiel zu den Russen in die großen Buchten wollten, um da die Kabel anzuzapfen, haben sie das auch gemacht. Da haben sie sich halt hinter solche lauten russischen Frachter gesetzt und sind da mitgefahren.
Und man macht das natürlich nachts, wenn Stopf finster ist.
genau.
Und genau, das war hier eben auch der Fall. Das war um 9.30 Uhr, was?
Um 9.30 Uhr war die Kollision, also beziehungsweise der Incident. Wir wissen nicht, ob es eine Kollision war, aber vermuten es. Und was halt doof ist, ist, wenn der Tanker unvorhergesehen bremst oder seinen Kurs ändert. Und ist halt zwar so ein Tanker, bremst halt wirklich doll langsam. Also das ist halt irgendwie eine sehr langsame Angelegenheit und der lenkt auch wirklich sehr langsam. Aber das U-Boot ist auch wirklich echt dicht dran. Das heißt also, da sind halt dann nur so 40, 50 Meter oder so was, maximal Reaktionsgeschwindigkeit, was halt bei den so 10 bis 15 Knoten, die so ein Tanker fährt, halt auch nicht viel ist. Das heißt, da muss man dann halt schon unmittelbar reagieren. Und das Standardmanöver ist halt nicht zu bremsen, weil man kann ein Schiff nicht so schnell bremsen, sondern auszuweichen. Das heißt also halt einfach, möglichst alle Ruder hart irgendwie Backbord oder Steuerbord, je nachdem, was sich gerade anbietet.
Und so sehen die Schäden noch aus an dem Tank?
Und so sehen für meine Begriffe auch die Schäden aus. Es gab jetzt die Einwender bei den Kommentaren in meinem Blog, dass die Delle ja zu weit an der Seite, also zu weit oben ist, also zu weit oberhalb der Wasseroberfläche. Nur muss man dazu bedenken, die Fotos waren jetzt eine ganze Weile später. Das heißt, es kann durchaus sein, dass der Tanker mittlerweile entladen wurde. Das heißt also, dass diese Stelle vorher sehr viel weiter unter Wasser war. Und es kann auch die Kollision mit dem Turm gewesen sein zum Beispiel, sodass er da relativ weit oben ist.
Ja, das war wie unter Wasser, also der war wirklich komplett entladen bei den Fotos. Deswegen haben sie es auch erst nicht gesehen, denke ich mal. Denn die ersten Berichte haben nicht von einer Delle gesprochen, sondern da hieß es noch, es war eine Welle, und eine Welle hinterlässt ja keine Delle im Bildschirm.
Nee, vielleicht nicht so eine Runde.
Also das war die zweite Erklärung. Erst hieß es ein Angriff, dann hieß es, es war eine Tsunamiwelle, die von einem Erdbeben ausgelöst wurde. Die großartigsten Erklärungen.
Ja, was er aber nur in 3,4 auf der Richterskala gemacht hat. Also das wäre irgendwie so ein kleines...
Also es ist immer sehr interessant, so was zu sehen mit was für kreativen Erklärungen, die Leute dann kommen bei solchen Fällen. Also um dann nochmal auf diese U-Boot-Geschichte zurückzukommen, mir hat mal einer in einer Bahn, den ich getroffen habe, das war ein lustiger Bekannter.
Klingt jetzt nicht so plausibel?
Nein, also der, der fuh mit der Bahn über die Strecke von Hannover nach Berlin und saß dann neben einem Typ und wir kamen ins Gespräch und der erzählte mir halt, dass er für die NATO im Kalten Krieg in Dänemark gesessen hat und dass die da akustisch quasi das Meer abgehört haben. genau und dass die also hören wollten, quasi wenn die Russen da mit ihren U-Booten ausliefern und er hat mir also die lustigsten Sachen erzählt und eine Sache war eben genau, dass die das mit den U-Booten so gemacht haben. Die haben halt nicht ein U-Boot auslaufen lassen, sondern die haben so ein Konvoi auslaufen lassen mit ein paar alten Dieselfrachtern und ein, zwei alten Diesel-U-Booten, eins vorne, eins hinten und aber so richtig laute, so mit kaputtem U-Boot und noch, da hörst du dann akustisch, wirst du so, da kannst du halt zehn U-Booten daneben haben und hörst nichts. Also das war schon immer quasi die Methode.
Das heißt, sie hatten so Geräuschfrachter, die sich gezüchtet haben, dass sie möglichst noisy sind.
Auch möglichst nicht repariert, damit es schön laut war. Der hat überhaupt ganz lustige Sachen erzählt, der Typ. Also eine andere Geschichte, die er erzählt hat, das passt jetzt gar nicht, aber ich erzähle die trotzdem, war, dass die beiden Abhördienste sich natürlich auch gekannt haben und dass sie sich zu Weihnachten immer auf den gegenseitigen verschlüsselten Kanälen Grüße geschickt haben, in dem Zweifel des jemals anderen. Ich weiß nicht, ob da was dran ist, aber ich finde es eine sehr schöne Geschichte.
In dem Zweifel des jemals anderen? Das hat schon Stil, ja, da kann man nicht viel sagen.
Also wir haben auch mal nachgeguckt und wenn man bei Wikipedia zur Straße von Hormus guckt, in der englischen Wikipedia gibt es da eine Historie von Kollisionen von US-U-Booten mit Tankern und da gab es schon drei in den letzten Jahren und einer war auch tatsächlich mit einem japanischen. Und davon ist das schon sehr...
Da war das Untersuchungsergebnis extrem geil und zwar, also ich kann nicht beurteilen, ob es stimmt, aber und zwar haben sie irgendeinen hydrodynamischen Effekt festgestellt, der dazu geführt hätte, dass das U-Boot von dem darüber hinweg fahrenden Tanker nach oben gesaugt worden sei. Keine Ahnung, vielleicht kann ja irgendjemand mal was dazu sagen, der von Hydrodynamik hat, aber so angeblich ist da dieses U-Boot nach oben gesaugt worden und deswegen in diesen Tanker reingefahren. Wahrscheinlich war es auch dieses Mal irgendwie ein Wetterballon, der das Leuchten der Venus...
Die haben einfach verkackt, dass die einfache Erklärung sagt. Occam's Razor. Es gibt immer wieder solche U-Boot-Unfälle, ich sammel die auch so ein bisschen. Also es gab zum Beispiel einen japanischen Trawler, der in seinem Netz dann ein amerikanisches U-Boot gefangen hat im Pazifik, wo man auch denken sollte, der Pazifik ist eigentlich groß genug. Oder es gab eine Kollision zwischen einem französischen und einem englischen Atom-U-Boot.
Die war auch großartig, der Atlantik ist auch groß genug.
Der Atlantik ist auch groß genug eigentlich. Aber da sieht man mal, dass die halt beide auch durchaus auf Stealth achten bei ihren U-Booten. Und zwar so gut, dass sie die auch selber nicht detekten können. Das ist schon, oder? Das ist einfach inkompetent, was ja die mir persönlich immer die liebste Erklärung ist.
Ja, ich weiß nicht, also...
Man weiß es nicht.
Also ich glaube, so richtig outright inkompetent würde ich den, glaube ich, nicht hinterstellen. Ein U-Boot ist halt wirklich teuer.
Ja, wir reden von den Franzosen. Sorry, sorry.
Eine interessante Buchempfehlung dazu zum Thema U-Boot-Fahrer ist das Buch Blind Man's Bluff. Das erzählt die Story der USS Swordfish, was ein Spionage-U-Boot der Amerikaner gewesen ist, mit dem sie dann halt in die Buchten bei den Russen reingefahren sind und da Unterwasser-Cable-Taps gemacht haben. Das heißt also, die Unterwasser-Telefonnettung der Russen angezapft haben. Da muss man ein bisschen zwischen Zeilen lesen, weil die natürlich nicht alles reinschreiben können, was da so war und sich noch ein paar Sekundärkörner schließen. Aber das ist durchaus schon interessant, das mal zu lesen. Und da beschreiben wir unter anderem, dieses Manöver, hinter einem großen Schiff herzufahren, ist der absolute Routine. Das kommt in diesem Buch bestimmt 30 Mal vor oder so. Das ist halt nicht irgendwas, was die nur selten machen.
Da ging es halt um eine Militärbasis, auf einer Halbinsel Balkan-Shutdown.
Das ist eine der Geschichten, wo sie halt so ein Kabel angezapft haben.
Was ich ja sehr krass finde, dass die Russen, die haben offenbar gedacht, wenn das ist weit genug weg und unwichtig genug, dass man da nicht verschlüsseln muss. Also das ist ein sehr interessanter Themenkomplex und da interessieren wir uns auch beide für und suchen immer, was da gibt.
Also die interessante Frage ist ja noch, wer könnte denn auch so rumfahren? Da kommt natürlich als einer der interessanten Verdächtigen natürlich die Israelis. Die haben ja einige U-Boote, die sie von Deutschland quasi geschenkt bekommen haben, also die mit deutscher Brandschafzellentechnologie funktionieren. Das ist Argument dagegen, dass die Israelis es gewesen sein könnten. Die müssten sich eigentlich nicht hinter so einem Frachter hängen, weil mit der Brandschafzellentechnologie ist es halt so, dass die so leise sind, dass sie vermutlich von den Sonars nicht ohne weiters erfasst werden können.
Die sind doch relativ klein, die U-Boote. Deswegen wäre es generell schwierig. Aber man weiß es nicht. Die Straße von Hormus ist eben sehr klein. Das heißt, da sieht man schon auch... Also ich finde das nicht stichhaltig. Vor allem, weil die Israelis auch im Mai angesagt haben, dass sie dann ihre drei Boote hinstellen und damit ein Nuclear Deterrent, also die Drohung eines Atomschlages gegen den Iran haben, einen Zweitschlag.
Zweit-Schlag ist das richtige Stichwort hier. Man muss halt verstehen, Israel ist ein sehr kleines Land. Und wenn die davon ausgehen müssen, dass der Iran Atomwaffen hat, dann können sie nicht davon ausgehen, dass irgendetwas, was sie in Israel auf ihrem eigenen Territorium an Raketen haben, einen iranischen Erstschlag überleben würde. Deswegen haben sie offensichtlich, so zumindest die Quellen, die wir so gefunden haben, die U-Boote, die Deutschland ihnen geschenkt hat, die haben Torpedoschächte, aus denen man Marschluckkörper abschießen kann. Und die haben einen relativ großen Brüchmesser, 935 Millimeter. Und die haben sich Marschluckkörper gebaut, also tomfähige Marschluckkörper, die genau in diese Schächte reinpassen, so die Berichte. Und was sie damit haben, ist eine Möglichkeit, den Iran mit Atomwaffen zu bedrohen, die der Iran nicht ohne Weiteres vernichten kann, weil er nicht weiß, wo sie sind. Das ist halt der Begriff Zweitschlagskapazität, also sozusagen der nächste logische Schritt in der Abschreckungslogik. Der Iran ist groß genug, die können schon immer unkurve Sachen verstecken, die Israelis im Zweifel nicht finden. Israel kann das halt nicht, deswegen halt diese U-Bootnummer.
Aber selbst wenn sie es könnten. Also allein die Drohung, dass du deinen Teleran platt machst, reicht eigentlich. Und ich meine, es ist eh nicht sehr wahrscheinlich, dass der Iran Israel nukleare angreifen will. Die wollen halt selber mit Zweitschlag drohen können. Aber ist egal, aus Israels Sicht ist es durchaus sinnvoll, bei einem Zweitschlagsdrohung am Start zu haben. Daher würde das schon passen. Aber naja, ich denke, wir werden sehen, weil Nachrichten über U-Boote, die in die Reparatur kommen, landen erstaunlich häufig in der normalen Presse.
Wenn es die Israelis waren, würden wir das nicht hören. Da gibt es Militärzinsen.
Ja, aber es gibt ja so Hobbyisten, die Satelliten tracken und es gibt auch Hobbyisten, die Flugzeuge tracken und es gibt auch Hobbyisten, die U-Boote spotten. Und deswegen ist es durchaus eine Restwahrscheinlichkeit, dass wir davon hören werden, wie wir jetzt ein U-Boot spontan in die Reparatur mustern.
Also diese Atomraketen bewaffneten U-Boote sind natürlich immer ein sehr interessantes Thema, weil es ja so eine Kristallisation dieses gesamten Kriegskontrollproblems ist. Also man hat da halt irgendwie so eine relativ kleine Mannschaft, die auf einem relativ kleinen Schiff ist, und zwar lange, Monate, über Monate hinweg, mit Atomwaffen und die zumindest im Prinzip die Möglichkeit hat, diese Atomwaffen auch einzusetzen.
Und allein auf so einem Schiff zu sein, was ja ein sehr enger raum ist, ist schon gefährlich.
Ja, deswegen suchen sie die Leute da schon ziemlich sorgfältig aus. Aber es gibt natürlich immer diese Geschichten, immer Rogue Submarines. Und eine der interessanteren Geschichten dazu ist, also eine der Theorien, ist ja die Geschichte über dieses russische O-Boot, was da so 1500 Kilometer vor Hawaii gesunken war.
Also eigentlich näher an Russland dran als an Hawaii, aber die Amis haben natürlich...
Ich hab nochmal nachgeguckt, die ist so, dass der Ort, wo es gesunken ist, der in der Wikipedia steht, ist umstritten. Ist nicht so, dass dieser Ort irgendwie sicher ist. Also ich hab eine Dokumentation gefunden, die behauptet, dass er wesentlich näher dran lag und ist insofern kritisch. Also dieses U-Boot hieß K-129, glaube ich. Die Geschichte ist die, dass dieses U-Boot gesunken ist. Und die Amerikaner haben auf ihren satellitenaufnahmen, bzw. mit den Early Warning Satelliten, mit denen sie Raketenstarts detektieren konnten, schon damals auf der Basis von Infrarot-Signaturen, haben sie an der Stelle, wo das U-Boot gesunken ist, einen kleinen Blip gesehen. Das heißt also, da ist irgendwas explodiert, was mit den Frequenzen, auf denen sie aufgepasst haben, also sprich für Raketenstarts, irgendwie zu tun hatte.
Das könnte auch der Reaktor-Meldung gewesen sein. Kriegst du so einen Unterwasserstart überhaupt mit, außer die Rakete geht das?
Na ja, eben, wenn es aber aus dem Wasser rauskommt. Die mussten damals noch über Wasser starten. Das waren kein Unterwasserstart-Fegende.
Ach so.
Oder nur knapp getaucht oder so.
Das war in den 60er Jahren.
genau, das ist schon ziemlich lange her. Die Geschichte ist interessant. Die ist auch relativ ausführlich. Da gibt es so Dokumentationen. Eine der interessanteren Theorien ist dieses Buch Red Star Rogue, in dem die Theorie ausgebreitet wird, dass der Unterseeboot-Kapitän oder eine Gruppe von Leuten auf diesem U-Boot versucht hat, einen Nuklearangriff auf Pearl Harbor zu starten. Und zwar mit einer Rakete.
Eigenmächtig.
Eigenmächtig. genau. Eigenmächtig oder halt mit Wissen von irgendwie, keine Ahnung, irgendwelchen Leuten in der sowjetischen Führung. Die interessante Idee dabei ist zu sagen, also man könne doch dann diesen Angriff den Chinesen in die Schuhe schieben. Und jetzt kommt der interessante Twist dabei. Das nämlich der, also zumindest, wenn man der einen Dokumentation glauben darf.
Haben die Chinesen schon Atom-Urboote gehabt damals?
Äh, ja.
Damals? Echt?
Also zumindest hatten sie Urboote, von denen man davon ausging, dass sie möglicherweise in einer Lage wären, Clare A.
Also es war unklar genug, dass...
genau, außerdem hatten sie schon ballistische Raketen, also das wäre auch so. Und der Twist, der jetzt in dieser Dokumentation kam, war, dass offensichtlich das Uran, was sie hinterher gefunden haben in dem Ölfleck bei dem Atom-Urbot, was von der wahrscheinlich beim Abschluss explodierten Rakete stammt, also die Isotopensignatur von chinesischem Uran aufwies. Wutt. Das heißt also, die haben sich... Das klingt ja krass. Also wenn diese Geschichte stimmt, dann haben sie sich offensichtlich so weit die Mühe gegeben, halt dafür zu sorgen, dass es nicht wirklich aussieht, wie eine chinesische Atomwaffe.
Das wäre natürlich elegant, wenn du so als russischer Premier, die Chinesenlos werden willst, dann sparst du dir natürlich viel Stress, wenn es die haben, die machen.
Also es würde halt irgendwie so in diese Geschichte reinpassen. Also es gibt natürlich Leute, die meinen, das ist alles Bullshit und es ist da irgendwie weiter weg gewesen, passt alles hinten vorne nicht. Wie gesagt, ich finde die Theorie natürlich viel hübscher.
Super.
Und die Amis haben ja dann mit irgendwie dieser Glomar Explorer dieses Schiff geborgen, also dieses U-Boot.
Das ist eine großartige Räuberpistole. Den Link werden wir diesmal dazutun. Da können wir nur empfehlen, dass ihr euch das mal schön durchlesen, denn das ist echt hervorragend. Also die Glomar Explorer ist extra für den Zweck gebaut worden. Es gab einen Vorgängerschiff, das hieß irgendwie Glomar Challenger. Und das war aber nicht groß genug. Und auch die Glomar Explorer war nicht lang genug, um das komplette U-Boot zu beinhalten. Also das war ein Spezialschiff, das sie gebaut haben mit einer Spezialkralle. Ich meine, logistisch ist das unglaublich, wenn man sich überlegt, so ein U-Boot wiegt ja auch ein bisschen was. Und man muss 5.000 Meter tief überhaupt erst mal reichen. Und da muss man genug Kraft aufwenden, um das hochzuziehen. Also das ist schon von sich aus echt unglaublich. So und jetzt ist es halt so, dass die Russen natürlich wussten, ihr U-Boot ist gesunken. Aber sie wussten wohl nicht genau wo. Denn die Amis haben zwar so einen Sonar-Grid gehabt auf dem Meeresboden und wussten daher, wo das gesunken ist. Und die Russen ahnten schon, was die Amis machen wollen, als sie mit dem großen Forschungsschiff kamen. Die offizielle Legende war, dass sie Mangan-Knollen großartig genau Mangan-Knollen auf dem Meeresgrund untersuchen wollen. Was übrigens tatsächlich gemacht wird, wissenschaftlich, ja.
Die wollten also die Geschichte, was sie wollten, sie fördern. Also weil der Typ, den sich engagiert haben, um dieses Boot zu bauen, Howard Hughes, war halt so einer von den richtig durchgeknallten Milliardären im Amiland, der halt viele Sachen für die Amerikaner gemacht hat. Und der hat diese Geschichte wohl gemacht, um seine, seinen Steuerhinterziehungsverfahren loszuwerden.
Also das Schiff hat vorher schon andere ähnliche Aufgaben gemacht. Die haben Probebohrung in großer Tiefe gemacht, um damals die Theorie der tektonischen Platten zu beweisen. Also das war schon nicht völlig abwegig, dass die Forschung machen würden. Aber Manganknollen, naja. Übrigens, Deutschland fördert auch gerade Manganknollen. Bei Australien habe ich noch nie irgendwo im Fernsehen gesehen. Das ist nicht völlig abwegig.
Haben wir da ein U-Boot verloren?
Wahrscheinlich.
Also interessant ist ja dann, also die haben dann dieses U-Boot gehoben und dann haben sie da auch die die Leichten von den sowjetischen Matrosen geborgen und haben die tatsächlich würdig bestattet und haben dann 1993, also im Zuge der allgemeinen Entspannung, haben sie den der Sowjetunion dann ein Video von dieser Zeremonie, wo sie halt die Überreste der sowjetischen Matrosen nochmal siebestatten übergeben und die Schiffsglocke, die Schiffsglocke, genau, ja, der CAA-Chef hat ihnen die Schiffsglocke wiedergegeben. Insofern, das war, ja.
Ja, also warum dieses U-Boot für die Amis so spannend war, weil eben sie wussten, dass da Atomraketen an Bord sind. Das war bekannt.
Und Atomtorpedos.
Und Atomtorpedos. Und diese Raketen hatten eine Reichweite von 1200 Kilometern, waren also auch durchaus...
Also die bekannte Reichweite. Also es gibt auch noch Gerüchte, dass sie noch weiter reichten. Was interessant ist für diese Frage eben, ob sie heute irgendwie...
Also die Amerikaner haben ansonsten keinen Zugriff auf sowjetische Atombomben gehabt. Und das wäre quasi der erste große Fall gewesen. Und deswegen haben sie da also auch keine Kosten und Mühen gescheut und haben also dieses unglaubliche Boot gebaut. Ach, eine Sache noch. Die schwedische U-Boot-Affäre habe ich hier noch, wo wir gerade bei U-Booten waren.
Die schwedische U-Boot-Affäre?
Das ist eine großartige Sache. Also es ging nämlich damit los in den 80er Jahren. Das war quasi die Spätpanikphase des Kalten Krieges. Und da sind dann plötzlich an den Küsten Schwedens U-Boote gesichtet worden. Und die schwedische Presse sollte dann die Geschichte verbreiten, dass das die Russen seien, die den Angriff planten. Und die Schweden haben unglaublich Panik geschoben. Und später ist dann rausgekommen, dass die U-Boote NATO-U-Boote waren, die das inszeniert haben, um Olaf Palme abzusägen, der damals in Schweden Premier war und eine sehr neutralistische Politik gefahren hat. Der wollte also sich nicht festlegen, ob er jetzt pro oder gegen USA oder Russland ist. Und da haben sie also gedacht, da werden wir jetzt mal ein bisschen Panik spüren, von wegen die Russen kommen. Tja, und das ist eigentlich schon damals so ein bisschen klar geworden. Also es gibt inzwischen schöne Fernseh-Dokumentationen auch dazu. Und es gibt eine längliche Wikipedia-Seite, die ich an der Stelle empfehlen kann. Aber es gibt auch schöne Fernseh-Dokumentationen, wo sie die Leute interviewen von damals. Und das sind auch also zivile Wissenschaftler, die meinten, das war damals schon ein bisschen komisch. Und so erzählen, was da gelaufen ist und wie sie dann plötzlich keinen Zugriff hatten auf irgendwelche Sachen. Da sind, glaube ich, auch Froschmänner gesehen worden. Also die haben fast, die sind sogar so weit gegangen, dass sie irgendwie versucht haben, zu simulieren, dass jetzt quasi ein Land, ein seegestützter Landangriff geplant. Also völlig absurde Geschichte. Aber es war halt Kalter Krieg und die schwedische Bevölkerung ist richtig in Panik ausgebrochen damals. Und das ist also eine legendäre Falls-Flag-Operation sozusagen.
Spannend.
So läuft das.
Wir tun nur mitten links. Was mir gerade noch einfällt zu dieser Rogue-Submarine-Geschichte, diese nordkoreanische, also diese Nordkorea-Geschichte.
Ach, dieses südkoreanische Schiff, was sie da versenkt haben, ist auch echt eine unklar angelegenheit.
Das ist ja ursprünglich völlig unklar.
Sie haben wohl das Torpedo gezeigt, hieß es, das war irgendwie mein letzter Stand. Sie haben das Torpedo gezeigt und behauptet, das käme aus nordkoreanischer Fertigung. Das ja auch nichts heißt, das kann ja immer noch...
Dann haben sie sich jetzt aber glaube ich darauf geeinigt, dass gerade niemand Bock auf den Korea-Krieg hat oder so ähnlich.
Ja, aus naheliegendem Grund.
Obwohl, das stimmt gerade nicht. Also momentan machen die Amis gerade, haben eine Flugzeugträgerkampfgruppe in Südkorea stehen und machen eine dicke Manöver mit den Südkoreanern in umstrittenen Gewässern.
Und die Südkoreaner haben gerade Roboter ausgerollt, in der DM-Zeit hast du es gelesen.
genau, diese...
Samsung-Roboter und die Begründung war super, nämlich, dass ihnen ja der Nachwuchs wegbleibt. Also mit ihrer Demographie haben sie begründet, dass sie jetzt Kampfroboter ausrollen müssen. Und das ist ja auch cool, eigentlich, weil die Begründung wäre dann auch bei den Russen und den Deutschen akzeptabel. Wir haben die gleiche Demographie.
Ja, wir haben nur keine DM-Zeit, die wir da...
Nein, aber Kampfroboter, ich meine.
Zumindest können wir sie...
Gut, wir haben Drohnen, das ist ja auch...
Wahrscheinlich können wir sie exporten. Ja, stimmt, wir haben Drohnen. Ja, ist richtig. Obwohl die Deutschen noch ein bisschen hinterher sind. Gut, dann war es das, glaube ich, mal wieder.
genau.
Mit Alternativlos, Teil 2.
Wir verbleiben, haben Fragen offen.
Mailadresse für Feedback findet ihr wie immer im Blog. Wir versuchen noch so ein bisschen in der Audi-Qualität zu drehen. Wenn ihr uns dafür ein bisschen flattern wollt, dann flattert uns bitte. Und ansonsten hören wir uns wieder beim nächsten Mal. Auf Wiederhören.